pardon tu as été touché une deuxième
fois oui là où du coup je me suis testé
parce que du coup il y avait dans la rue
des tentes partout dans les pharmacies
donc du coup j'ai fait le test ppr tout
une dent menée et là du coup je me suis
aperçu que là je l'avais officiellement
une deuxième forte quand on était
physiquement physiquement si j'ai pas eu
beaucoup de pas beaucoup de fièvre on
perte de goût courbatures mal de tête
beaucoup de tout et c'est surtout
psychologiquement
psychologiquement je j'avoue je suis
tombé dans une sorte de langue des
pressions que parce que tout le monde
dit que la troisième vague ça va être
une vague sickology où les gens vont
être atteints psychologiquement
toi tu étais rentré dans une dépression
chanter dans une langue dépression qui
est je m'en sors mieux que d'autres qui
ont des responsabilités qu'on des
commerces qui ont des restaurants qui
ont des personnels à charge moi je suis
tout seul donc à l'ennemi zahner ça ne
concerne que moi mais c'est surtout
vis-à-vis de ma famille mes enfants que
mes enfants que je voyais déjà moins à
cause du confinement il a du coup quand
on est malade bah du coup on y voit plus
du tout quoi donc là est sentie très
seule
seulement parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
tout le monde m'a appelé ici je veux
dire que babu cyril évidemment tout le
monde n'y a pas un chroniqueur qui n'a
pas ap c'était même gênant j'ai apprécié
que je méritais pas autant d'attention
donc c'était c'était presque gênant mais
c'est vrai que les marques d'intention
qui bouge qui touche beaucoup mais que
tout comme on a une famille en plus dur
très éparpillé dans toute la france plus
que ma mère habite biarritz mais sera
bits dans l'est où notre bourgogne
je les voyais pas et on se voyait en
haut de baisse voir par exemple de noël
bat tout est annulé parce que moi j'ai
pas envie de refaire prendre de risques
parce que même si je suis j'ai été testé
positif au négatif hier je me dis que je
sais pas je suis pas sûr qu'en et quand
même con négatif peu de temps près comme
ça on sera plus contaminant qu'est ce
qu'il paraît enfin j'ai eu des échos qui
m'ont dit que tu étais vraiment très
très mal qu un moment tu te dis
peut-être fait je vais arrêter je vais
sa cause de benjamin ce qu'on les adore
et que kim aperçoit en prod2 mais
nouvelle qui m'a donné un conseil qui
m'a dit achète un oxymètre qui permet de
mesurer de façon instantanée le taux
d'oxygène et sont dans ce sens et c'est
vrai que habitude 95 en tout 95 et sans
le son on a une si jeune dans le sens
tout à fait normal et en dessous de 95
sur tontine 92 on est en sous oxygène
donc ça veut dire que tu es que virus en
train de prendre de l'ampleur dans le
corps et qu'on est vraiment sur la voie
de l'hôpital et du coup il a fait
acheter ou les burdett raison et du coup
je lui ai commencé à le prendre et je
vais
chiffres mais c est au fur à mesure que
cbc je passais sous 92
je suis assez sous 90 après 89 88 87 et
la russie mais là c'est je vais tout
droit dans le mur tir que le virus a
pris de l'ampleur et ça y est je pourrai
plus l'arrêter et je commençait même à
me dire des choses complètement débiles
c'est que discutant plus comme le moi je
suis un fan de télé je vous regarder
mais je regardais aussi bfm et c est en
fait moi ça me parle que du coc vide le
vide est donc du coup je vais tous les
jours les chiffres qui montrent etc et
j'en étais presque à un moment je me
suis mis à penser complètement débile
j'ai dit à ma copine ça qu'ils jugent
dépassé malheureusement je lui ai dit
genre je crois que j'aimerais bien
partir à l'hôpital tout de suite parce
que ça se trouve cissé dans plus
longtemps s'ils sont sûrs a plus place
et je préfère y aller maintenant quand
rien encore la place parce qu'après de
telles que je serai plus prioritaire
c'était normal et que du coup va je vais
croupir je vais mourir comme ça dans la
cour c'est débile mais ça fait un moment
de ne plus revoir vos proches depuis
revoir pas assez peur c'est sûr qu
maison sans s'inquiète et je sais pas
dans l'ordre des choses que les enfants
s'inquiètent pour leur père moi je
m'inquiète pour cesser ce qui se passe
avec 7,7 mais moi je m'inquiète pour eux
mais que ce soit eux qui s'inquiètent
pour moi je mets en plus et ils ont
d'autres chats à fouetter ma fille et le
fils étudie en plein examen et cetera le
savoir qu'elle m'a appelé trois fois par
jour pour savoir comment j'allais et
cetera j'avais envie de les rassurer en
mettant le voyez bien que je poussais
beaucoup téléphone que j'avais pas trop
le moral parce que d'habitude je suis
plus heureux joyeux et la wild bunch
même si j'essayais de masquer j'étais
j'avais pas la grande forme et ont du
coup je vais bien que ça l'affecté